Taliban leaders are making new threats
against US troops in Afghanistan after
President Trump cancelled secret peace
talks with the militants and Afghan
leaders right now negotiations to end
the nearly 18 year conflict and bring US
troops home are in turmoil Charlie
d'Agata is in Kabul Afghanistan's
capital Charlie what's the Afghan
government saying this morning well
Anthony it was the announcement of the
cancellation that took everybody by
surprise here including the Taliban who
warned that it would lead to the loss of
more American lives talks between the
u.s. and the Taliban seemed on the verge
of a breakthrough until it all fell
apart
President Trump tweeting that he called
off peace negotiations in the wake of
last week's Taliban attack they killed a
US service member in at least 11 others
which caught president ghani's
government here on the backfoot our
peace talks continue we don't think so
under the stage and that other bombshell
that Taliban leaders and separately the
President of Afghanistan were going to
secretly meet at Camp David we caught up
with presidential spokesman sediq
Siddiqui we were looking at a meeting
where we're going to have president
Ghani and representatives of the Taliban
and President Trump a Camp David a very
important place that's huge well I don't
know I can't comment on that right now
I don't have that much detail of any
meeting that could have happened in Camp
David maybe because it was supposed to
be a secret Camp David the country
retreat where presidents down the years
have invited world leaders to broker
some of history's most famous peace
deals the president's decision to host
the Taliban there on the eve of the
anniversary of the 9/11 terrorist
attacks has angered members of his own
party here the Taliban's use of violence
like suicide bombings and assaults as a
tool for negotiating peace now only
promises to prolong the war
now the president spokesman told us
there is actually some relief that those
talks were cancelled it shows you can't
talk to the Taliban while they're on the
attack and they can't be trusted
Tony Charlie d'Agata forests in Kabul
Charlie thank you very much the United
States went to war in Afghanistan 18
years ago this month we want to offer
some context to what is America's
longest war about 14,000 American troops
are still in the country and over the
course of the war more than 2,400 US
servicemen and women have died there and
the u.s. still has spent more than two
trillion dollars so the big question how
did we get to right now
well seven days after the 9/11 attacks
President George W Bush signed a
resolution authorizing the use of force
against those responsible for 9/11 al
Qaeda with the support of the Taliban
who ran Afghanistan at the time nineteen
days later the u.s. launched its first
airstrikes on Afghanistan and the
Taliban government quickly fell but the
Taliban had a resurgence in 2006 taking
advantage of weak Afghan government
leadership and launching hundreds of
attacks each month President Obama took
office in 2009 and order ordered a troop
surge to handle the violence Afghan
security forces took over the war in
2014 but thousands of US troops remain
due to continuing instability since then
the Taliban has steadily gained more
power and more territory Taliban
militants now control more afghanistan
that at any time since 2001
when the u.s. invasion happened giving
them more leverage at a crucial time and
a crucial seat at the negotiating table
and that's where we begin senior foreign
affairs correspondent and Face the
Nation moderator Margaret Benin is at
the White House with more on that part
of the story Margaret the big question
now is why was his meeting really
canceled well good morning Gail I'm told
by both US officials and senior Afghan
officials that the reason goes deeper
than the president's tweet which claimed
it was all due to that deadly bombing on
Thursday
keep in mind negotiators went back into
talks right after that bombing and
neither side had actually agreed to a
ceasefire a senior administration
official I spoke with told me it did
though become apparent that the Taliban
negotiators at the table did not have
full command and control of the fighters
on the ground who carried out that
attack
in addition key details of the agreement
were still unfinished the Taliban still
has ties to al-qaeda according to US
intelligence that's key the Taliban did
publicly say that they refused to travel
until a deal with son was signed and
Secretary of State Pompeo told me
yesterday and Face the Nation that there
was confusion on this point but he did
believe that the Taliban did intend and
they planned to have them show up at
Camp David you also have to keep in mind
there's a backdrop of disagreement
within the Trump administration itself
over whether that drawdown in u.s.
troops from fourteen thousand nine 8600
which is what the president previously
announced needs to happen with an
agreement or can happen without one
Margaret there always seems to be more
to the story than what the president
tweet so what happens now that's the big
question Secretary Pompeo said the
president will have to make a decision
on unforced posture that means is he
going to revisit his previously
announced decision to take the number of
US troops down from 14,000 to 8600 he
said he was going to do so around the
same time that the Taliban and the
Afghan government received their
invitations to Camp David so new
circumstances does that change
Pompeyo said he didn't know the answer
to that yet he did leave the door open
to returning to talks but that's gonna
be really tough the one constant gale
that we hear from both President Trump
and every single Democrat running for
the nomination is in 2020 is that they
want to end US involvement in this war
so for the Taliban this may just be a
matter of waiting and as Charlie said it
will continue to be deadly the Taliban
said they will use violence to gain
leverage right Margaret the world is
watching thank you very much